good afternoon everyone my name is
Daniel Anderson I'm a student at
Hillsdale College and I'm participating
in the Washington Hillsdale internship
program this semester interning at
Freedom Works I'd like to introduce dr.
Ronald J post read Oh
he is the Charles and Lucia Shipley
chair and the American Constitution
associate professor of politics and Dean
of the Graduate School of statesmanship
at Hillsdale College he also a senior
fellow with Hillsdale Kirby Center
having earned his BA at the Claremont
McKenna College and his MA and PhD in
political science from the Claremont
Graduate University dr. prasarita was
senior fellow at the Claremont Institute
in an academic fellow of the foundation
for defense of democracies he is author
or editor of seven books including
Woodrow Wilson and the roots of modern
liberalism and American progressivism a
reader now please join me in welcoming
dr. post Rita
all right well good afternoon it's great
beer at the Kirby Center thanks to
everybody for coming out and thanks toe
to everybody tuning in online I guess
tuning in is the right phrase I'm lying
although I'm I'm I'm a bit old-fashioned
so pardon me if that's not the way to
put it but I'm also in the unenviable
position of coming after dr. Kevin
Porteous whose presentation this morning
I thought was was great and I fear how I
may look by comparison but I'll do my
best
as dr. Porteous explained in the
presentation concluded in the
presentation the administrative state
that we have today
very much stands in sharp contrast with
the principles of constitutional
government and in fact senator Lee made
much the same case in his remarks
earlier in fact while today the
legislative and the executive branches
of our national government remain
stalemated and divided the bureaucracy
keeps on going keeps on turning along
and the bureaucracy really is where
almost all of the relevant activity is
today in government now we know that in
our system Congress may make the laws
but over the last century or so these
laws have often been written so vaguely
so broadly that the real policy-making
has been done or is largely done by
bureaucrats by bureaucrats in those
agencies that our laws have created for
the purpose of implementing and
administering the details the examples
of this scenario are of course abundant
we don't need to go deeply into them dr.
Porteous cited several of them in his
remarks earlier but I just want to give
you a couple quick ones to underscore
the point and really to get us started
in figuring out where it is and how it
is all of this came came to happen in
American history which is really that
might
today dr. Porteous mentioned our friends
in the Environmental Protection Agency
the EPA and the EPA is of course
presently in the process of issuing
final rules regulating greenhouse gases
among other things now due mostly to the
concern over impacts that such
regulations would have on the economy
you may recall that a similar scheme of
regulation garnered strong bipartisan
opposition in the last Congress and
failed to pass in fact you may remember
that then Senate candidate Joe Manchin
won election from the state of West
Virginia due in part to a television
commercial which showed him or depicted
him shooting a copy of the legislation
with a high-powered rifle so that's how
unpopular this was however in spite of
this legislative failure in spite of it
being rejected by your elected
representatives these rules and many
like them are right now in the process
of becoming law such a maneuver is of
course possible because when Congress
enacted the Clean Air Act and its
subsequent amendments it defined the
EPA's power in such broad and vague
terms that it amounted to a delegation
of the very legislative power that is
supposed to according to the
Constitution lie only with Congress it
was given to the agency in a similar
example this is one that hasn't been
mentioned yet today we know that
Congress back in 2008 considered and
voted down a taxpayer-funded bailout of
major American automobile manufacturers
nonetheless as you may have noticed
Treasury Department went right ahead
and proceeded to bail out both General
Motors and Chrysler how did this happen
I was able to do so because in the
previously enacted Troubled Asset Relief
Program legislation tarp which was
supposedly passed for the purpose
of bailing out banks and other financial
services entities that law had been
written so vaguely that the Treasury
Department under its terms had ample
discretion to divert funds to a wide
array of activities that had little or
nothing to do with the financial
services industry just the way the law
was written same kind of lawmaking by
unelected bureaucrats of course as a
central piece of Obamacare dr. Porteous
went through a lot of the details there
and if you think about the Obamacare
legislation as long as it is it really
is true it doesn't say much
it just confers power on various parts
of the federal bureaucracy just this
past week of course we know that as it
has played out in the news the Obama
administration has pressed its assault
on religious liberty in this country and
it's done throat done so through the
bureaucracy by issuing rules through the
Department of Health and Human Services
that require private entities even
religiously affiliated entities like
Catholic schools and hospitals required
requires them to pay for services
through Obamacare that are fundamentally
at odds with the tenets of their faith
now know there's a big uproar about this
but whom do we hold accountable after
all the people of this country don't
vote for the bureaucrats that issued
those rules and thus can't hold them
directly accountable nonetheless these
rules of course have the force of law
they are in fact the functional
equivalent of laws just try violating
one of them you will find this out very
quickly again in a way the temptation is
to demonize the bureaucracy I'm all for
that of course but Congress really is
responsible Congress really is
responsible Congress passed a piece of
legislation in this case the Obamacare
legislation that was so vague so broad
it essentially pushed lawmaking power
over into the bureaucracy and so rules
which now will deeply affect the health
of all
Americans never mind their religious
liberties they are going to be made and
are being made at a furious pace by a
collection of bureaucrats who are
largely insulated from direct public
accountability kind of makes you wonder
why people get all worked up about
elections in this country if in the end
they may not matter that much well this
was not the system that our founders
established for the founders who wanted
to secure individual rights they
implemented a constitutional design
centered on separation of powers facts
centrally outlined some of this this
morning fundamental aim of separation of
powers was to safeguard the natural
rights of citizens to safeguard them
against the possibility of arbitrary
government this essentially was the the
point of the remarks by dr. Porteous and
Senator Lee this morning just talk
briefly then about a couple of them talk
about first principle of non delegation
it's very straightforward if the
separation of powers means anything at
all it means that one branch of
government may not have the bulk of its
power is exercised by another branch if
you have that you don't have separation
of powers pretty simple
second one closely related to that first
one no combination of functions no
combination of powers within a single
agency within a single set of hands
think about this a little further those
making the law should also be subject to
the law being forced upon them by an
independent authority it's one of the
fundamental safeguards of our Liberty
right I know what I'm voting for a law
this thing's going to be enforced on me
too that's important those involved then
in executing the law can't make up the
law as they go they don't get to decide
what the rules are on the spot and then
enforce them on you in an arbitrary way
instead they have to enforce laws that
have been
previously established by a separate
authority that would mean for instance
that when the Department of HHS goes
about implementing Obamacare they
shouldn't first get to make up the rules
that they're then going to implement
it's pretty fundamental and finally
under this principle separation of
powers those on whom the law is enforced
can then have their cases judged by an
authority entirely separate from that
which brought the prosecution now from
what we've heard today we know that
those basic common-sense essential
constitutional principles stand in sharp
contrast to the way in which
bureaucracies exercise real power first
there is the basic and unavoidable fact
that the administrative state today is
built on governance by expertise at the
expense of government by consent and
thus lawmaking power is delegated away
from our elected representatives over to
unelected so-called experts second look
at the combination of functions within
single agencies dr. Porteous read that
great description of the Federal Trade
Commission written by Gary Lawson you
could apply that description to many of
our federal agencies today bear that in
mind many of them exercised lawmaking
executive and judicial functions all at
once particularly this is true of our so
called independent regulatory
commissions the National Labor Relations
Board for instance has been in the news
much lately and that's that's how the
NLRB functions essentially so we have
all these fundamental differences
between the founders constitutionalism
and the principles of our administrative
state today and thus the question should
should arise how did this happen how did
this happen how did we get to this point
how did the move from the principles of
our founding to the modern
administrative state occur well it's a
long a complicated story I think I've
only got five or six hours so I'll try
to
only an hour okay well I'll just give
you one important part of the answer and
that of course lies in the American
progressive movement American
progressive movement came to its height
at the turn of the 20th century and
really it was it had become impatient
with the limits imposed on the federal
government by the Constitution in order
to handle the vast array of new
redistributive and regulatory activities
that progressives had in mind for the
national government it was necessary to
erode those constitutional limits it was
necessary also to come up with an
administrative system that was actually
capable of managing this whole new set
of federal programs and endeavors we
didn't have the apparatus in place at
the time and it shouldn't surprise us
that those calling themselves
progressives today remain strongly
attached to this kind of discretionary
expert governance that had in fact been
launched by their ancestors in the
original progressive movement this idea
that we get in modern bureaucracy again
was outlined by some of our speakers
this morning of taking a significant
portion of government and grounding it
not on the basis of popular consent but
on the basis of expertise this was a
fundamental aim of American
progressivism it helps to explain the
progressives fierce assault on the
founders separation of powers
constitutionalism this idea was
introduced in the United States by
progressive reformers who had themselves
learned the principle from what was then
the cutting edge theory of history and
of the state which had been developed in
nineteenth-century Germany and in this
regard no one I think was more important
to the origins of the administrative
state in America than the two figures
that I wanted to say something about
today in the remainder of my remarks one
you
you no doubt have heard of and one
probably you have not so let me start
with the one that you've probably heard
of Woodrow Wilson Wilson of course
served as the 28th president of the
United States he had been also a leading
academic advocate of progressive ideas
long before his entry into politics a
lot of people don't understand how how
active and how prolific and academic
Wilson was for decades prior to his
entry into public life in fact much of
his contribution to progressive thought
came in the 1880s through a series of
important essays and speeches that he
gave this idea of taking administration
taking agencies taking bureaucracies and
shielding them at least to some degree
from political influence get getting
them out of being subject directly to
the consent of the governed in other
words this had been around of course in
in the United States for some time at
least since the reaction against the
19th century spoil system and this is
the case in which many jobs in the
federal bureaucracy were doled out on
the basis of one's affiliation with a
particular party or candidate and not
very much based on the person's actual
skill or merit so you had the
establishment of the Civil Service
Commission under the Pendleton act in
1883 this marked a significant victory
for opponents of a spoil system however
it really took the progressives starting
with Woodrow Wilson and and Frank good
know who's the other figure I'm going to
talk to you about in a moment to take
this rather narrow inclination from the
civil service reform movement right
which is basically we want it we want to
kind of cleanse politics out of it we
want to get it out of administration
purify administration clean it up it
took the progressives to take that
little inclination and turn it into a
much bigger broader thoughtful critique
comprehensive critique of American
constitutionalism and really part of a
broader
argument for political reform now while
the opponents of the spoil system
certainly wanted to shield
administration from political cronyism
they really didn't offer a new theory of
administration itself instead it was the
progressives and they were concerned
less with eradicating the evils of
political cronyism although that was a
problem then they were in creating a
realm of neutral administrative
discretion shielded from direct
political accountability now Woodrow
Wilson introduced this concept of
separating politics and administration
of treating administrative governance
and everything involved in it as an
object of study entirely separate from
politics from constitutional governance
and he introduced it in a series of
essays in the late part of the 1880s
Frank goodno then expanded on this
Wilsonian concept in the 1890s and
eventually published a book in 1900
titled politics and administration if
you're ever having trouble sleeping you
might you might pick up a copy it's
better better than any pill you can take
the fundamental assumption behind the
vast discretion that progressives wanted
to give to administration was this it
was a trust in or an optimism about the
selflessness the competence the
objectivity and the capability of
administrators and therefore a belief
that the separation of powers checks on
government were really no longer
necessary and really no longer just so
if you think about the framers of the
Constitution the framers of the
Constitution instituted the separation
of powers out of fear of the abuses of
government fear that the permanent
self-interest interested nests in human
nature that they thought was there could
make government a threat to the natural
rights
of citizens so if that's what the
framers thought then the advocates of
administrative discretion concluded that
those fears even if they had been
well-founded at the time given the
history of the founding era really no
longer applied in the modern era in
their time
therefore they argued administration
could now be freed from the shackles
which had been placed upon it by the
separation of powers and it needed to be
freed in order to take on the new tasks
that progressives had in mind for the
national state this key assumption
behind this idea of separating politics
and administration is very much
exemplified in Wilson's political
thought there's a strong progressive
belief in the Enlightenment in the
disinterestedness of administrators
which stood as an instructive contrast
to the permanent the permanent
self-interested Ness that the framers of
the US Constitution saw in human nature
you think of that famous passage from
Federalist 10 where Madison talks about
the latent causes of faction being sown
in the nature of man and thus the limits
on government must be permanent as well
that's the contrast here so we've got
this sobriety about the potential for
tyranny that led the framers to
circumscribe carefully the authority of
government versus the progressives
passionate optimism and therefore
they're passionate optimism fueled their
call for the maximum discretion for
administrators now we have to be careful
here we don't want to suggest that
somehow the framers of the constant
Constitution denied discretionary power
to the national government far from it
certainly no reader of Federalist paper
number 23 or many other Federalist
Papers I could point to no reader could
could reasonably draw such a conclusion
rather the framers understood that such
discretion while occasionally necessary
had to be channeled
through the forms and through the law of
the constitution in order to be safe for
liberty
therefore as Alexander Hamilton
explained in Federalist number 23 and
elsewhere the vigorous discretion that
the national government needed to have
was to be made safe by quote the most
vigilant and careful attention of the
people the most vigilant and careful
attention of the people and quote now
how do the people go about exercising
that vigilance well the officers who
exercise the discretion on their behalf
must be made to do so in a system of
clear electoral accountability that's
the only way it can work within the
confines of the rule of law within the
constitutional framework and it is
precisely that kind of political
accountability your ability to change
what bureaucrats do through voting that
kind of accountability that progressives
wanted they wanted to free
administrators from that that was the
problem from the point of view of the
progressives for the progressives there
was something special about civil
servants it somehow raised them above
the ordinary self-interested nests of
human nature now such confidence came
from a faith that progressives had in
the power of history the idea that
history had elevated public servants to
a level of objectivity our bureaucrats
would supposedly be able to disregard
their own private or particular
inclinations in order to dedicate
themselves to the objective good and
because of this disinterestedness then
restraints in their discretion were no
longer necessary now Wilson subscribed
thoroughly to this doctrine of
historical progress he learned it from
reading German state theorists like
Georg Hegel and Johann blue jelly among
others and from his own teachers like
richard te lee who himself had received
his education in
Germany Wilson came to believe
essentially that history had solved the
problem of faction in direct opposition
to Madison's claim that the causes of
faction are sown they are permanently in
the nature of man Wilson believes in the
power of history history has helped us
overcome that right therefore human
nature is no longer a danger in
democratic government Wilson wrote
frequently that the power of the
national government could be unfettered
because one faction or one part of the
country was no longer a threat to the
rights of another our real problem
Wilson argued was not majority tyranny
but minority tyranny now with the threat
of faction having receded as a result of
historical progress
Wilson argued that a new understanding
then of the ends and scope of government
was an order this new understanding
required an evolutionary approach to
reading the Constitution one in which
the ends and scope of government are
determined not so much by looking to the
pre established law of the Constitution
not to its original intent not to what's
written there but instead to the new
demands which were being placed upon the
government by contemporary historical
circumstances and the Constitution had
to be adapted accordingly for example in
his campaign in 1912 which ran under the
banner of the new freedom Wilson urged
that the rigid mechanical what he called
the Newtonian constitutional system be
replaced by quote the Darwinian
perspective that we ought to adjust the
Constitution we ought to see it as an
organic entity and it ought to be made
to fit the ever-changing environment
constantly adapting to its environment
Ryan hence the Darwinian label Wilson
also blamed the separation of powers
theory for getting in the way of that
that reading that new reading of the
Constitution that he believed was
necessary it's making the national
government unable to handle the
asks that history now requires of it and
the people wanted to take on this is
what Wilson said on the campaign trail
in 1912 quoting the trouble with the
theory and this is the theory separation
of powers the trouble with the theory is
that government is not a machine but a
living thing it falls not under the
theory of the universe but under the
theory of organic life it is accountable
to Darwin not to Newton it is modified
by its environment necessitated by its
tasks shaped to its functions by the
sheer pressure of life no living thing
can have its organs offset against each
other as checks and live and then it's a
central part of speech he gave on the
stump in 1912 so Wilson saw the
separation of powers as a hindrance to
efficiency right efficiency was to be
valued over everything else efficiently
efficiently translating perceived
majority opinion immediately into public
policy as Wilson claimed in 1885
efficiency had become the preeminent
principle in government because history
had brought us to an age where
administrative functions of government
were most important this is what Wilson
wrote then quote the period of
Constitution making is passed now we
have reached a new territory in which we
need new guides the vast territory of
administration but that's where the real
action was in government coming up into
the future which is sort of remarkable
if you think what I said at the
beginning of my remarks that this is
where this is where the action is today
in the bureaucracy
even though bureaucracy doesn't sound
like something very exciting to talk
about Woodrow Wilson at least get
excited about bureaucracy in the various
works that he wrote on administration
and which which I should add were
largely responsible for launching the
whole discipline of public
administration in this country and you
still see lots of discussions about
Wilson and Wilson's administrative
theory and all the public administration
literature but in those works
Wilson's thesis was that it was far
better far more efficient for a
professional class of experts instead of
a multiplicity of politicians with
narrow competing interests far better
for that expert class to handle the
complex business of the modern state now
to the objection that one might make you
might say well gosh of trusting
administrators with such discretion
doesn't seem to comport with the
Constitution's Constitution's
distribution of power right to that
objection
Wilson responded that administrative
principles and constitutional principles
or distinct and thus that constitutional
limitations could not easily be applied
to the exercise of administrative power
the administration really lie outside
the bounds of constitutional restraint
so you might be able to apply a
separation of powers to the political
branches but that shouldn't be applied
over to administration so you take
checks and balances for example that
interferes with efficiency it shouldn't
be applied to the exercise of
administrative power Wilson wrote quote
give us administrative elasticity and
discretion free us from the idea that
checks and balances are to be carried
down through all stages of organization
now this argument that freeing
administrators from closed political
control it was grounded in the
characteristic progressive confidence in
the expertness and objectivity of the
administrative class for years Wilson
had been urging special education for
future administrators at the elite
universities he referred to the
patriotism of administrators to the
quote disinterested ambition of the new
administrative class and he says this
will come out of our elite universities
right Wilson himself of course was a
Princeton alone
Wilson is thus a critical figure for the
progressive vision of administration
because he's largely responsible for
applying optimist
about administrators to the American
system Wilson assumed just as the German
thinker Hegel had assumed that if you
took an administrator and gave him a
secure position given tenure give him
good pet insulate him from political
machination z-- this would relieve that
civil servant of his natural
self-interested nests so the the
particular narrow things with which he
might be concerned those would be taken
care of then he would be free to do the
public good and that's what he would
focus on now his model Wilson's model
for this rather interesting conception
of administrators he freely acknowledged
was almost entirely foreign to American
constitutionalism he acknowledges this
yet it was his own notion of the
distinction between administration and
politics that made this okay right that
made it okay essentially to import what
was essentially a Prussian model of
administrative governance into the
United States he was a great admirer of
the Prussian bureaucracy precisely
because under his vision administration
was to be insulated from politics and
was to be insulated from the
Constitution an administrative system
that had come from a monarchy could be
brought into the American Republic
without harming our Republican
institutions if you keep administration
separate then why do we care what system
our administrative model came from so as
Wilson asked in his hugely influential
essay titled the study of administration
he asked the following quote why should
we not use such parts of foreign
contrivances as we want if they be in
any way serviceable we are in no danger
of using them in a foreign way we
borrowed rice but we do not eat it with
chopsticks and quote that essayist is
chock full of such allegedly witty
remarks
again another bother another cure for
insomnia if the politics administration
doesn't do it Wilson study of
administration that's that's the heavy
dose so Wilson knew therefore he knew
that his vision for administration was a
novelty in America in fact when he later
taught administration in the 1890s
he said that there really was only one
author other than himself who understood
administration in this way
who understood administration as a
separate discipline not subject to
politics and that was Frank good no this
other fellow I want to talk about now
Frank goodno produced almost all of his
important work while a professor at
Columbia University he had been brought
there by his mentor a guy by the name of
John Burgess to teach political science
and law and really he became their the
first to teach administrative law in the
United States prior to teaching at
Columbia goodno had spent a year
studying in France and Germany as I
mentioned and he would go on to finish
his career by the way at Johns Hopkins
where he served as president in fact
until his retirement in 1929 he was also
the first president of the American
Political Science Association so a very
influential intellectual largely obscure
too in sort of the common history now
although good note was a student of
Burgess he was certainly much more
radical than Burgess and his
progressivism goodno looked for ways
that American national government could
be modified to accommodate progressive
policy aims and he thought that the goal
could best be accomplished by freeing
administration to manage the broad scope
of affairs that progresses believed
needed government intervention like
Wilson goodno argue that government
needed to adjust its very purpose it's
very organization to accommodate modern
necessities and like Wilson he believed
that history had made obsolete the
founders dedication to protecting
individual rights
and it made obsolete their consequent
design of this carefully limited form of
national government so in his book
titled social reform in the Constitution
goodno complained about reverence for
constitutional law which he regarded as
quote superstitious he regarded it as an
obstacle to genuine political and
administrative reform in his book titled
politics and administration goodno made
clear that his push for administrative
reform was not simply or is not even
primarily aimed at correcting the
corruption of the spoil system that's
all well and good but that's not what
this is about
goodno said rather administrative reform
was instrumental to the end of achieving
progressive big government liberalism
that's what this is about
if we don't enlarge the discretion of
our administrative apparatus if we don't
free it from political control then our
government will be incapable of doing
the kinds of things that we progressives
have in mind
right we're if we're going to get what
we want we need the kind of government
that's built to do it we need to remove
these limits that that's the bottom line
for these guys now if we understand
administrative reform that way as a
means to securing the broader aims of
progressive liberalism that is what
makes the work of good no and Wilson to
certainly so much more significant to
the development of modern American
thought in politics than had been the
case with the civil service reform errs
good knowing his fellow progressives
envisioned an almost entirely new
purpose for the federal government and
thus government itself needed to be
viewed through an historical lens the
principles of the original Constitution
could no reasoned may have been
appropriate for the founding era but now
he says quote under the present
conditions they are working harm rather
than good and quote and again the error
that the founders made was not in
constructing government as they did but
rather in taking their construction and
thinking it would transcend their own
age and thinking it was appropriate not
just for their time but for all time in
thinking that this idea of human nature
was permanent as opposed to evolving
essentially the founders from the point
of view that progressives did not
realize the historical contingency the
historical dependence of their views
that their views were only coming out of
the conditions of their own day and thus
couldn't be brought forward into other
eras modern situation according to
goodno called for less focus on
constitutional principle it called
instead for a much greater focus on
empowering and perfecting administration
he even repeated using almost the same
words wilson's proclamation from 1885
that the nation had to move from
constitutional to administrative
questions if you think the founders
constitutionalism and its focus on
government's permanent duty to protect
individual rights they thought this was
an impediment this was the problem this
is the obstacle to the marked expansion
of government that we progresses desire
and so if that's the problem
then that idea has to be discredited
okay
good no Wilson the progressives they
understood the political theory of the
founding very well they were well
educated men they knew that this idea
that the government's primary duty is to
protect natural rights they knew it came
from this thing this theory of social
compact right that's a theory think of
the Declaration of Independence of
course which held that men are naturally
endowed with rights prior to the
formation of government and therefore
they their consent is required to create
government and they only consent to
government insofar as it will protect
their natural rights this idea goodno
acknowledged quote was permeated by the
theories of social compact and natural
right and quo
and he condemned those theories as quote
worse than useless worse than useless
since they quote [ __ ] development
right so the focus on individual liberty
prevents the expansion of government
that's the bottom line
take the separation of powers its limits
on government those come from this
founding era concern for individual
liberty and thus good no offers instead
a critique of that idea based on
historical contingency based on
historical evolution that was then this
is now new historical circumstances
beget new principles now instead of
understanding rights grounded in nature
where the individual possesses them
prior to the formation of government
right where God gives you your rights
not government good no urge the
understanding of rights that are in fact
granted by government itself good know
remarked favorably upon European trends
in those trends the understanding of
rights was contingent upon government
here's good know in 1916 commenting
favorably on the idea of rights which
was then current in Europe quote the
rights which an individual possesses are
it is believed conferred upon him not by
his creator but rather by the society to
which he belongs what they are what your
rights are what they are is to be
determined by the legislative authority
in view of the needs of that society
social expediency rather than natural
right is thus to determine the sphere of
individual freedom of action
close quote so you have the rights that
it is convenient for your society for
you to have at that given time and those
might not be the right you had twenty
years prior and they might not be the
same right you have twenty years later
now goodno found it necessary to go
after the idea of natural rights because
he knew the idea of natural rights is
the foundation for the requirement that
government be based upon
and the rule of law this principle of
government by the consent of the
governed this was a problem for good no
it's a problem for those who shared his
vision of administrative power right
let's you see that from the examples
that I gave earlier you see it from the
discussions that came this morning
how much do elections really matter
anymore in this country if you're
concerned about government by the
consent of the governed this is a
problem the empowering of administrators
as the progressive saw it was justified
not because not because administrators
had the consent of the people but rather
because the administrators were experts
in their field because they had been
educated on the issues over which they
were to be given regulatory power they
know better so good know therefore
wanted to improve administration but he
wanted to improve it not by making
administration more accountable to the
consent of the governed but in fact by
making it less accountable could no
acknowledge that the doctrine of the
sovereignty of the people was an
integral part of the American political
culture he therefore acknowledge that
this aspect of our political culture
would be a bit of a difficult hurdle for
his vision of administration to overcome
but goodno said we have administrative
experts now available they're being
educated they're being produced by our
elite universities and the urge that
they be employed and empowered with
significant discretion to manage the new
tasks that progressives had in mind for
the national government and so good
knows work while certainly more obscure
than Wilson's in fact made its
contributions to the progressive cause
by thinking really in detail how our
legal system how our constitutional
system would have to be changed in order
to accommodate governance by
bureaucratic agencies you think of some
of senator Lee's remarks
from this morning he talked about the
Administrative Procedure Act and this
whole body of law and Court decisions
which kind of facilitates so much
independent governance by administrative
agencies well Frank good knowing the
progressives are really the pioneers in
in those practical considerations what
is our law have to look like what kind
of principle should our courts be
governed by if we're going to give this
greater discretion to administrative
agencies because it doesn't come out of
the Constitution after all if you think
about the main tenants then of the
progressive vision for administration
articulated by the likes of Wilson and
good no they really have come to have a
powerful influence in the administrative
state by which we are governed today
again that can be seen I think just from
the examples I gave from the examples
that were given earlier today for the
whole story of course certainly it would
be necessary to examine the translation
of progressive ideas into the actual
reshaping of American government that
took place during the New Deal the
franklin roosevelt and in fact if you
look at Roosevelt's remarks many of them
refer back to the progressive ideas you
look at his 1932 Commonwealth Club
address in particular he points back to
Teddy Roosevelt and especially to Wilson
as sort of the intellectual foundation
for the New Deal so you have to look at
that that's of course a story that would
have to wait for another day unless
you'll want to stick around after that'd
be okay too I think for our purposes
however today we'll simply stick to the
intellectual roots of the modern
bureaucracy in the Progressive Era which
is what I've tried to sketch here very
briefly so I'll stop thanks for your
your patience and your attention I'll be
happy to take any questions
thank you for that my name is jeiza
Watsky I'm from Bethesda Maryland
have you read the book Phillip Drew
administrator no but I know I know of
what you speak okay I read it recently
and it was written by a fellow named
house Colonel house who I believe was
the political father of Woodrow Wilson
he sort of discovered him as a
politician and suggested he might be
brought along to run for president are
you familiar familiar with that history
yeah I certainly am I mean house I
wouldn't call him the sort of kind of
political father of wills he was
certainly a close confidant and had you
know at some times more than others a
great deal of influence on Wilson's
thinking inside the White House we
ultimately waned but the reason I bring
up Phillip drew administrator is because
in that novel which was written by House
he actually eviscerates the Constitution
and sets up philip drew the hero as the
man on the white horse and I was
wondering if Wilson actually saw himself
as the man on the white horse I think
it's safe to say that Wilson Wilson saw
himself as a man a man on the white
horse in a lot of ways that is to say
when I when I mentioned a moment ago
that there's this contrast between the
framers and the progresses right someone
like Madison says human nature there's
this permanent self-interested miss in
it and we're always going to be factious
and while we're capable of great things
and capable of governing ourselves and
everything else we're also always going
to have the self interests can be a
problem in democratic government because
what do you do when a majority of people
wants to take away the liberty of
minority of the people in order to
benefit themselves Wilson says no
histories overcome that right
human beings are no longer like that or
they're not nearly as much like that as
they used to be
well one might take a look at the
history you know take a look at the
history of the second part of the 19th
century and you might say politics still
seems pretty self-interested you have
pretty corrupt pretty factious one of
the most facts just you know times you
can think of probably human beings don't
seem to have lost much of their innate
self-interested Ness Wilson's argument
Wilson developed in a whole argument for
progressive leadership that what a
progressive leader was there to do was
to see past or to see through all of the
typical contentions which still existed
on the surface of politics and to be
able to pull out from underneath them
the real unity the real kind of
togetherness the real mind of the people
that was their latent that was that's
there in the public mind the real leader
the user the phrase maybe the man on a
white horse in a way knows the mind of
the people better than the people
themselves and so all of these sort of
limitations and all of these all the
ways in which the Constitution kind of
carefully circumscribes the power of
government because you know a fear of
what we might do to one another were it
completely unfettered from Wilson's
point of view a progressive leader and
we certainly understood to be himself
could see through that and could pull
out from from the people the kind of
unity that history had given them and
they this is by the way not an uncommon
characteristic of L thought the same
thing and when you think about this I'm
often brought to I'm always brought back
to Madison in Federalist 10 and
Madison's comment about about man and
and the connection between his reason
and his self-love and that that's when I
think of what Wilson or Teddy Roosevelt
that's what I think of that that I think
very astute observation of Madison's yes
sir this is a question from our online
viewers Theo from Atlanta Georgia asks
you've mentioned how the progressives
had great trust in humanity has their
belief in man's goodness been shaken by
the failings of the
aggressive state the questioner seems to
dare to suggest that the actual facts of
history may somewhat diverge from the
the faith and the optimism look I mean
it's it's ironic in a very he in a
terrible way
you know these notions about the sort of
end of factionalism these notions about
you know being able to free ourselves
from constraints because we're less of a
danger to themselves are all just at the
beginning of the bloodiest century in
human history
I think about it and this is true by the
way of the 19th century German thinkers
who really spawned this the idea of
historical progress right the century
leading into the 20th century this is
not something about which to be
optimistic look the the idea here is to
always push the goal-line further ahead
right and so the argument would be and
it is by a lot of modern day progresses
well we might be wrong about where the
end of history comes but we know it's
coming it's just over the horizon or no
maybe we were wrong about it being at
this point but it's you know 50 years
off or whenever it is and so the the end
the end is always the goal is the end
zones always pushed away you're always
in the red zone to use a football
analogy and so no I don't think it
dampens much enthusiasm although there
are some some progressives who through
the course of the 20th century certainly
became a little bit disillusioned with
with progressivism as a result of
historical reality just one quick
example of that that I might give by the
way right now it's very hard for
agencies to get away with doing anything
without without it being litigated by
the courts and that's the result of a
phenomenon that started to take place in
the 1970s called capture theory and
prior to that point in the 20th century
you know you had this great optimism
about administrators all we need to do
is get off their backs all we need to do
is free them from from control
and they'll do the right thing and
liberals themselves actually became a
bit disillusioned with that as they seem
to recognize that well wait a minute if
you take human beings and put them into
administration they still act like human
beings there's still a self-interested
as they would have been anywhere else
and there is still a self-interested is
as other people and so there there came
along a much greater skepticism about
administrators and that's when you
started getting a lot of the liberal
interest groups developing and taking
agencies into federal court so you get
groups like the NRDC or the Sierra Club
places like this who would go into court
and they'd say we don't think these
agencies are regulating hard enough
they're not regulating zealously enough
and so we want to use the courts to put
the feet of administrators to the fire
not because of liberty reasons but
because we want more regulation than
what they're giving and they become
captured by their self-interested nests
so that that that idea of capture theory
which is not very common in in in
bureaucracy is you know it's part of a
disillusionment about about what happens
on the ground yes yeah my name is Bree
McMahon I'm from Potomac Maryland had
two questions one the American
Revolution was a reaction to the tyranny
that we lived under one were there no
administrative despots in the world that
would have served as a counter factual
to the progressive idea back then
and number two who were who were the
intellectual opponents primary election
opponents of Wilson and those people
that existed back then well your second
question I'm going to take first because
the points it points to the the problem
generally there weren't very many
intellectual opponents to the
progressives so in fact years ago when I
first started reading and writing about
the progressives and teaching the
progressives I started thought of course
for the first time and I was one of
those new courses you're staying kind of
a week ahead of the students and I put a
section in the in the course for
the end called Progressive Era
conservatives or something like that I
figured well put people you know like
you know I don't know how Lodge and Taft
and Ellie who root and others who kind
of oppose progressive policies and I'll
put them in there and and you know it
was sort of read about the debate that
was going on and when you read a lot of
these guys what you realize is you know
why the battle was lost because they're
using progressive language and what you
see in the more you look into it what
you discover is this stuff is in the air
and it's in the water in the second half
of the 19th century and at the turn of
the century the progressive mindset this
way of thinking historically about human
nature and about government it's in the
air in the water and it's in the
language and so even folks who might
have opposed this or that particular
policy are nonetheless of a kind of
mindset and it really reflects the
extent to which the American University
had been radically transformed between
1860 and 1900 just a massive change if
you look at the contrast from one point
to the other and and and what had
happened was at this time if you wanted
a higher degree you went to Europe to
get it and so you had all these
Americans going off to Europe and
especially to Germany to get these
advanced degrees and if you were an
American college and university it
became the trendy thing to do it's what
you did in order to be prestigious to
hire some of these European educated
academics back onto your faculties and
so you had colleges which had been very
Orthodox and which still had very
Orthodox boards of Trustees for instance
but they thought well the thing to do is
to get us some European you know newly
minted European PhDs that's what all the
elite places are doing and so you get
them in all these institutions and this
starts to filter its way that transforms
institutions of higher education in this
country and it starts to filter its way
down and and you know as Aristotle tells
us you know bad ideas at the top they'll
corrupt the regime and it takes a long
time but but you know in terms of the
intellectual argument then it explains
why there's very little opposition
and intellectually there's a various
political opposition of course it's why
the proposals of the original
progressives often didn't get very far
had to wait for the New Deal but there's
really not serious intellectual
opposition and that and that's that's
partly why yes sir
my name is David Greenberg I'm from
Statesboro Georgia and my question is
dealing with some of the Friedrich
Basquiat had said in his book the law
that misuse and use of morality serve to
justify legal plunder and I want to know
if that same thing misuse and use of
morality also helped give rise to
progressivism well I mean certainly
might say the misuse of of it did what a
lot of people don't realize was that the
the progressive movement was intimately
bound up with one of the more important
religious movements of that time the
social gospel movement and what you had
I have a whole separate speech I give on
social gospel but but what you had you
had I won't give it now but what you had
there was essentially the turning of the
state into a God and so what history is
is essentially God making himself
manifest on earth and and the state is a
kind of heaven heaven on earth and so
for many progressives not all of them
some were some were quite secularized
but for many progresses Wilson included
makind of religious fervor and certainly
a kind of a sort of moral superiority
the idea that you know one had to read
on the Holy Spirit then history kind of
embodied the Holy Spirit so it is true
right a misuse of morality on the other
hand you have to understand that the
idea that they were seeking to attack
seeking to replace the idea that man has
liberty and that this that there is an
obligation for this Liberty to be
protected that's also a moral idea all
right you can't can't forget that so
it's not like any assertion of morality
is somehow inherently a threat to
Liberty it's it's really in the
Progressive Era and this a misuse then
of morality yes sir this will be our
final question for dr. post read oh
that's another question from the online
audience Lauretta from Akron Ohio ass
you've shown pretty well that ideas have
consequences if progressivism and
conservatism are the two battling ideals
in America how do we ensure the
conservatism wins do we look to
education or something else well I mean
you know by the answer to that I'd you
know I don't know where I'd be but oh I
guess I should say I do have the answer
to it and it's why I am where I am it's
I think the answer is in education the
answer really is contained in the
response I gave the gentleman a moment
ago that the reason why we have we have
the problems that we have today are one
of the main reasons why is because we've
had bad ideas coming in and infiltrating
the system now for a long time you have
to remember this this the fight that
that we are in it's not a short-term
fight you know it's not going to be won
in one election or two elections it took
these guys a hundred years to do this so
you know these ideas have been filtering
down and and in my view the way out lies
in education until you until you educate
different principals then you're not
going to get any kind of permanent
victory thank you very much appreciate